and this is this is a little bit front
nd a little bit full stack architecture
a kind of a talk and so if you find
yourself struggling to place where this
is this is about that's actually why
we're here we're talking about the
transitioning of stacks and how stacks
are moving towards the front so and and
the primary overall question that I want
to start people off with is how do you
distribute your software I think this is
something that we don't really think
about because we're primarily this you
know concern at this conference and in
our jobs about writing code about
maintaining code about deploying code
and and and I think I think a lot of us
like when we're in the mobile world
which you know it's it's it's a lot of
difference it's a quite a different wall
from the web dev world we develop in
Xcode we build to IPA artifacts and then
when they deploy to the iOS App Store an
android same thing I enjoy studio to
apks and deploy to Android and what do
we do for the web it's kind of a little
bit up in the air right we're not really
sure and things are kind of in flux and
they're all of these cool tools from
different cloud providers and you're
like I don't know all of them sound
really cool so this is the question
we're gonna explore today distribution
of your web software to all these
browsers and and what goes in between so
my name is Sean I go by six on the
Internet I'm a big proponent of learning
in public I think is the absolute best
way to sort of accelerate your career
that's why I'm here that's that's why I
think is beneficial for everybody to
practice I'm mostly a moderator of the
art / practice subreddit where it is 150
thousand of us talking about react
hiring each other
discussing best practices and react and
you're welcome to join us and I also
work in nella Phi and this is not a
notify specific talk but Noah is a huge
proponent of the jab stack as a better
architecture and we'll talk about why
the reasons why that might be so let's
talk about Jeff stack basic definition
what is what is the JM that stands for
JavaScript API is a markup and we'll
explore why this is
thing interesting at all because I think
for the people who've sort of been
around for a while
and this is a fancy word for static
sites come on like how can I do a forty
minute presentation on this and it is
true in one sense but things have
changed in the past 20 years of web
development that make this a totally
different proposition from what it used
to be that's why we're here and in fact
if you're a developer of any sub tenure
at all
you're already glazed over with all the
stacks right I mean I just pulled I just
went on the Wikipedia page with stacks
and I just pulled all these names and
I'm sure you can name even more I was
just at Tracy Lee and Rawal sales
presentation on the Pam stack which is
more about process and mentoring and and
it's not so much about specific
technologies so I'm gonna I'm gonna take
I'm gonna put this all in context so
that you can actually understand the
history that we come from so in the
beginning when we when we made the very
first web page it was actually that easy
right like we post we put something on
it we put raw HTML code on a server and
that's the that's the very first certain
web page and that was it you Rick you
you hit a server you requested that data
and it came back served back that
request and you displayed it on a
browser and I think obviously that's
that scales pretty well and then it all
started going wrong from there because
the first thing we wanted to do was to
start making things that were dynamic
right so we we used to code with like as
simple as a notepad code or a leave HTML
send it to browsers now we actually have
to run a program behind it so for
example in this countdown page to to run
the content you have a running program
that you know checks the time and
generates the page on request and then
outputs that HTML and the only way to
refresh that content was to literally
refresh the page obviously once you have
some running logic you also want some of
their persistence and that's that's
something that gets you closer to the
modern day version of
and if anything sort of cruddy which you
know the the typical profile is like
it's something like a wordpress where
you have in database backing behind some
kind of logic behind a server which
which generates that request every
single time someone visits your site and
that actually pretty much tells the
story of the 1990s 2000s it was it was
actually a lot of fighting empathy and
I'm glossing over so much detail because
there was whole debate over what kind of
what kind of stack actually would win
out and and the most successful ones it
ended up being the open-source stacks
but what definitely didn't look like
that was the case for much as much of
those that period but that is that is
what became prevalent and dominant which
is the lab stack and so that model of
simple delivery from you know just
writing that page and then delivering it
directly to the browser became a little
bit more indirect we started to have
these separate machines from what we
code on and those are those are boxes
that we're running the lab stack with
and the and the and you know and then we
have this request cycle right from from
browsers to the start to the server
generating HTML and sending out their
browsers again and back and just back
and forth and that's fine that's cool
there's some problems with that though
and we started we started to feel that
as as we sort of scaled in Indiana DNA
and had exploded and took over the world
so the first problem to sort of think
about is the need for caching layers so
so load balancing on one side of you
know I just put in representative boxes
there obviously there are different
names for different different kinds of
things and depending on your use cases
you're gonna have different technologies
that suit these things but some sort of
load balancing some sort of static
caching in between all these servers so
that you're reducing your load and your
and and just like when you hit the
physical machines on one box you need to
you need to go fill of a horizontally to
another and so that adds an extra layer
of complexity and the the core inside
here oh and then and then we added one
more core piece of technology that sort
of sidesteps all this and I just put
that in there as
as a CDN layer and and the core insight
here is that traditional stacks you add
extra layers of infrastructure and add
extra layers of static layers because
your fundamental assumption is still
that you have a running box somewhere
that generates your page on request
and I think I think that's that's the
core assumption that we're trying to
tackle today so the problems with some
of these we this is the standard list
that we sort of list go with and I'm
sure you can come up with your own list
of issues auto-scaling and some of these
have been haven't actually solved by
some of the platform providers right
like if you don't want to think about it
you can pay AWS Heroku to do all the
scaling for you release engineering
they're you know they're dedicated
services that have individually come up
to solve each of these problems but the
only problems the only reason we have
all these problems in the first place is
because we still have this core
assumption of a running server and and
the the the fun way to put this is is we
just put it my kind of slightly askew on
a deck and it all looks like chaotic and
we call this accidental complexity like
when we wanted to deliver our pages to
the user this is all the crap that we
have to go through to just make sure
things stay up and things get delivered
at a highly available manner so you know
is there a better way we'll see well I'm
just gonna collapse all of them into
sort of three mega factors and it's it's
primarily to do security because you
have a large surface area you know
injection attacks all that reliability
and that's and that's also including the
availability of your of your of your
overall system as well as complexity
slash cost I kind of put this together
because you can always pay more to have
someone else deal with a complexity for
you but or you can know is just handle
it yourself and deal with that
complexity yourself and so there is
there is one parallel trend over these
past 20 years that also was an
interesting but kind of toy concept
which is separating that concept from
the data generated model generating two
static pages and then only serving those
static pages from a
a man from the edge server and so this
this is kind of a toy no one really took
it seriously and and sometimes you don't
take it seriously to the point of not
having a logo and that's your jaw so one
of the earlier static site generators
and so iconic all these generation 1
SSDs because the only thing they do is
output 'html
from data and and they use sort of
increasingly available technology so for
example Bloxom over here was written in
PHP I think and and then and then a
little bit more modern one site shows
examples of Jekyll which was invented by
Tom Preston Warner a github
Hugo written with go also a new language
and middleman with Jas and so all these
are fine and those are those those are
simpler ways of sort of dealing with it
but not really serious for anything else
either then sort of blogs and marketing
sites so then we come to the next phase
of stacks right we had the lamp stack
and that was fairly successful and
obviously like Jas developers start to
get in there I was and now we started
talking about the mean stack and and the
whole sequence of this is that
JavaScript got serious over the exact
same time we standardize the language in
1997 and then very we've got very
excited in 1988 we had the next version
1999 we had ES 3 and then 10 years
happen that we don't talk about and then
and then finally we achieve some harmony
in 2009 and 2015 and now we have a
established annual cadence of JavaScript
releases and it feels like a lot more of
an established language that you can do
serious engineering of apps in so ok all
right we have some frameworks coming up
on the front end right we got ember
knockout backbone angular and then we
looked at the back end and we were like
yeah I mean looks like we can do all
that in j/s and yeah I mean we have the
rough equivalence of all these
technologies on the back end as well and
that that is the dawn of the full stack
JavaScript craze right do we and so and
so this is an one particular flavor of
full psych job is is the mean stack
right and this is coined by Val Karpov
actually only six years ago in 2013
and a lot of people actually identify
themselves as mean means that developers
today and you notice that we used to
have lab staff used to describe all the
server-side technologies and no front
end and now the mean stack has two
things on the back end and two things on
the front end right well well angular is
front end but I guess Express is kind of
like still back-end II but you can see
that things are slightly too slightly
moving over like you're no longer
concerning yourself with the operating
system okay so let's let's keep going
the other thing that starts to come up
with all these sort of front-end
frameworks is the phenomenon of
client-side rendering and routing so you
whatever you're doing you're you're
you're writing code to the mean stack
you're deploying those you're sending
over those html5 and GS sorry it just
five I guesses I don't know what this
logo is about but then you're sending it
to the browser and then instead of
getting a full refresh of the page for
faster speed and also a better user
experience you're just sending from j/s
incremental requests for data and then
rerender it on the client-side and that
is a slight improvement you probably saw
this first in your lives in Gmail right
and and and now it's taking over most of
the way that we deliver front-end web
applications so okay we've rewritten
everything in JavaScript so we haven't
really solved anything and we actually
added a new problem and that is that is
performance and so let's talk a little
bit about that one of the main if you're
in JavaScript Twitter at all you want
domain debates that always pops up is
the web performance of apps in a real
world so sense of performance budgets if
you do the math and you wanna you want
to have some assumption of like you want
to have a limit of 5 6 5 seconds times
are interactive you want to have a some
assumption of 400 kbps link 400
millisecond round-trip time blah blah
blah carry the one you actually worked
out to about 130 hundred Soni kilobytes
of critical path resources as a budget
for initial load
and so if you do the math that's that's
the maximum region that you're they kind
of you're allowed to deliver before your
page starts to be unusable in terms of
how slow it's how slow it takes to load
unfortunately we actually kind of
exceeded that in roundabouts in 2011 and
now now we're standing at about 400 K
for the median page and a lot of you
know a lot of pages bust that very
easily so you know the other thing the
other thing is also about the the
performance in terms of what we lose
when we move to single page asks so this
is the default output of create react up
a lot of metadata over here but in fact
the only piece of content is this empty
div div id equals root and then close
div and that's all you're given in a
standard create react app and obviously
so when you when you load a page you're
just gonna get a blank page until the
rest of JavaScript comes in and then you
load and you parson run that JavaScript
and then you see something on the screen
so that actually takes a long time you
have that HTTP fetch you have then you
fetch that J's bundle and then you
render the app and then your interactive
right so there's there's quite a there's
quite a lot of you know blocking
considerations going on here as we sort
of move our applications from
server-side generated pages to the to
front-end apps so we have all the same
problems as mean stack security
reliability complexity cost and we added
extra performance concerns
that's not exactly clear that it's
better but you know more people can
write it because Java C is more
accessible fantastic I think the the
mental model that we started to realize
was wrong was we were doing this we're
doing a request of HTML but then we were
requesting all the from the HTML
requesting all the assets then we're
decompressing parts and rendering the
jas and then went and then we're
rendering so the main trick that we
realized to get around this was
fantastic and this is my most proud
visual on this this talk which is we
flip the order and so now we can first
request the HTML within landing styles
when lining SVG's
and immediately show something on the
screen right we don't have to parse and
decompress J s anymore so we have
something on the screen and then we lazy
load all the other stuff and hydrate
them as we come along and that's what
the sort of newer generation of
frameworks all that you do together with
tooling like web pack and this is all
fantastic and it takes a whole bunch of
engineering and that's why friend come
and engineering as as a sort of
discipline actually gets more more and
more challenging over time so with that
trick we call it server-side rendering
we've actually been able to diminish TTI
quite a bit and that's fantastic right
then that seems like a little bit of
progress given this assumption that
you're still doing something like a mean
stack but you still you're still viewing
the world as like two very binary
options you have a full client-side
rendering sorry your full client-side
rendering and then your full service
side rendering and nothing in between
and it seems like the two very sort of
binary options and in terms of stack
choice it doesn't give you a lot of
flexibility in terms of like what else
you you could possibly do so if we
explore this I actually blanked out the
the middle parts so that's all happening
on in terms of stacks and then the
environment around the way that we that
we do web development is also changing
dramatically as well so the first thing
is get one right like right now we can't
imagine working without get four but for
a long time we're still ft peeing
servers were playing Rossa version and
whatever else came before that I wasn't
even around for that but but you get the
idea that that I think now the norm that
version control is a thing you pass the
Joel test first go you you're you're
doing CI CD this is established as good
practice like it's not I don't even
explain it it's like it's a given that's
the first trend and nullify we take it a
little bit further we do immutable
deploys we do deploy preview so like
before you when you make a PR we already
build and deploy that preview so you can
preview that page before you merge it in
in a in a production like settings and
and and we even do split testing like a
be testing of different branches based
on your deployments
and all this can be based on get just
that's the only API that you have to
learn which is fantastic to me second
trend there's five second trend is the
API economy so these are the rise of
companies that are dedicated only to do
the only to serve other developers
previously you have to own the entire
stack yourself now you're parsing it out
you partially portions stuff out that
you're not specialized it to step to
dedicated service providers I do not
ever want to do anything to do with
banking right I'd rather get play plaid
to do it for me like that will connect
to all the banking services in the US
for me I don't I don't ever want to
manage my own communication like SMS
infrastructure so I will use Twilio for
that I have one I'd rather hire the
world's best experts in these individual
things because that's not my main goal I
rather outsource that and focus on my
core business value all right API gotta
be fantastic
in fact there's there's there's even
more providers like just apart from just
the API is there's all these other
things and people actually and VCS have
actually been collecting all these in
gem stack landscape charts and this is
one from CRV and this is another one
from red point just to give you an idea
of like who are the players in each of
these fields definitely feel free to
take a photo but I'll also put this up
on my own site later on ink and you can
check and and think about like what are
the opportunities the too many
opportunities which people are sort of
crowding towards are its kind of in
these two fields of the halo CMS where
there's there's been a lot of
fundraising going on the utility API is
where and you know we already talked
about the API economy and they're there
quite a few unicorns in there and now
there's starting to invest in a little
bit more in the front in the front of
the stack so gatsby in particular having
having a being a being a particular sort
of high profile open-source project that
also raised a decent amount of funding
so and I also I also I also make a
special shout out to indie hackers so
people who are working on side projects
and just kind of by themselves and not
venture funded because I think I think
that's that's a strong use case for the
Jazz stack as well go check out this
article that I wrote on the in the
hackers page if you're interested in
that kind of thing
so the third trend that's going on is
the service trends obviously in 2014
Amazon launched a Turkish lambda and
then I was quickly copied by Microsoft
and Google and and I think at this point
in in time i won't i won't bother
explaining service to you but I think
the the proof it's it's been proven out
that it's been it's it's relied on at
scale
trillions requests a day by some of the
biggest you know production environments
you can you can you can work with that's
interesting because now you don't have
to manage your own servers so the the
the more like you can see that the
typical use cases of service of being
chipped away like you no longer have to
run a lot of your own logic you can hire
it out to dedicated api's and even for
your own logic you can run it on service
platforms that's very interesting the
others the other thing that's also going
on fourth trend is build tools right so
we have all these things that are
helping us engineer things really well
I always like to do a fun quiz obviously
this is typescript and flow and you
probably recognize NPM you probably
recognize yarn just a quick quiz anyone
know what that thing on there on the
left is is this is this is sort of like
a trivia quiz anyone yeah yeah Google
closure compiler so when people sort of
bundle their JavaScript they want anyone
optimize it a little bit a little bit
more typically you think about parcel
web pack and roll up
but GCC is actually really really good
for libraries all right and then the
final fifth and final trend is static
site generators here's the founder
another five Matt Billman talking about
it in Smashing Magazine this was their
top article surprisingly in 2015 in the
entire year and it's so interesting to
me because it's it was calling all this
thing so now if I used to be just a sort
of CDN layer and it just used to hosts
static sites and you just just used to
track static site generators as part of
like it's actually value-added service
and the note started noticing all these
rising github stars all this renewed
activity and static site generators and
they started to call it out and I think
and and here's that here's a site static
Jen
org and and you can actually see like
you know the the trends over time in
github stars and who's like who's sort
of on top in terms of projects and it's
very interesting because it seems like
it's growing rapidly and and with all
this available options in programming
you wouldn't it's not necessarily
obvious that that that the interest
inside senators is so high and I think
it's because like people want is some
something's something simpler in terms
of their deployment options there's also
a new generation of sexy generators and
these are all enabled by JavaScript so
what that gives you apart from the the
first generation jobs of generators is
templating components sort of integrated
styling options as well as rehydration
into some combination of server-side
rendered project at first and then
hydrating into your single page apps so
your you have a fully dynamic sites some
of these projects like I guess we call
themselves in fact they don't call it's
all static site generators anymore they
call it self PWA generators like you're
generating all the assets that you need
for progressive web app and and and when
you hit any other pages that have been
generated that you hydrate into a fully
sort of dynamic web app on the front end
and so these are some of the projects
I'm actually working on one for based on
Sapir but they're they're all they're
all enabled by JavaScript and that's
that's a lot more interesting so the
argument for static site rangers
generators of course is that instead of
doing work on request you're doing work
ahead of time at Build time and so that
you're you're at the very maximum limit
of what what the speed should be for
time to interact it because literally
you're requesting for static files from
the edge nodes in your CDN you don't
have to hit any origin and you don't
have to catch anything because you know
so there's no cache invalidation issues
you're literally that's the maximum sort
of limit and in terms of speed and and
so putting them on a chart you can can I
get some kind of justification CSS
tricks actually put it recently I think
like two two days ago put out a analysis
of let's put some hard numbers behind
what the different what the speed-up is
from sort of traditional server-side
rendering to jam stack and in the
fairly significant I don't have them
here though but highly highly recommend
talking about them and with the full
range of Java suit options you also then
have a full range of hydration options
so this this is this is the full chart
from Google talking about rendering on
the web and you have this spectrum
between full like server-side rendering
and full client-side rendering and this
this sort of options in between this
menu of options in between again I don't
have time to talk about every single
detail but you know I think as much as
you need for SEO as much as you need for
high performance as and if it doesn't
require sort of highly you know
authenticated data right like if the
data if what you show on screen changes
for every single user then there's no
point pre-rendering it just render an
empty shell for that page for that part
of your screen and then UCS to ping
api's and that is arguably lighter
faster and it's more responsive for your
for your users as well and we can talk
about that there are a lot of people who
have individual you know context
specific questions about this and I can
help you work through it
so take all these trends again these are
all the environment these like looks
like a meta environment around
programming right this is not strictly
programming but it kind of like is the
trends that are that are sort of
supporting it you have get workflow
build tool server this ap API economy is
and static sites sort of Renaissance
what do you get when you sort of put all
these things together and that's that's
the context at which we arrived for the
genatech right it's a modern
architecture for creating fast and
secure sites in dynamic apps with
JavaScript API simply writing markup
serving our web servers and that's the
most important thing and that's why
there's kind of like an underscore and
highlight underneath that and obviously
when we talk about serve adult web
servers obviously their servers there
it's just not yours so it's the same
thing it's the same thing as sort of
wireless cell phones like obviously they
don't want their wires work there
they're Wireless in fact CSS tricks the
founder of CSS tricks chris courrier
actually talks about instead it's like
Jeff Zack is kind of focusing on the
assets that are being built and
delivered like JavaScript API as a
markup and he actually realized that the
the core of all of the is static hosting
and so he called the sham stacks very
cheeky for so static hosting stack and
and his core insight is that everything
can be seedy and hosted that's the real
core of it like you don't have to use
JavaScript you don't have to use api's
but you can if you want to the main
thing though is that everything is
served from a CDN and that's why that's
what we try to we try to like make it
very clear it's not it's not and it's
why I put a slash through the end so you
don't have to use all three the main the
main thing is that you have your capable
of being served directly from CDN so
argument arguably that is the best
theoretical limit of performance right
uh-huh and and so and so then you use
for anything dynamically you static site
generators or data data-driven right so
the top the top field is the first
generation of static sites and these are
all the only generating HTML so that you
can generate that from data and then the
second here are all the next generation
static site generators which you can
generate from data but then also once
once they've delivered their assets to
the clients they can they can also
paying API is for anything dynamic
including of dedicated experiences and
high you know high frequency update
experiences as well for example one of
our top users and nullify is a sports
betting site with live updating sports
bets and then and you know that's that's
a very interesting use case for static
sites because you think that you know
you had you need some dynamic behavior
anyway so there are there are hundreds
more I have I have a link on a
presentation for some reason I wasn't
really thinking it through when I did
this but that just that's just a link to
stack gen calm and that that actually
gives you a really buffet of options
that the people are making so yeah you
don't have to you have you don't have to
use nullifying because I work at nullify
so I I want to make sure the the very
clear distinction between you know my
company's interest and and just like the
overall architecture that is more
interesting to the general audience so
you can use github pages the github
pages is arguably the original
progenitor of the gems that concept but
you can you host it on an s3 bucket you
can host it on a Raspberry Pi I don't
here the whole idea is that is simple
enough and portable by the way so you're
not locked in because the only thing
that you're using is is is building to a
static folder right so anyone can serve
that so that's so that's very good for
vendor lock-in and and yeah so like you
know nullify is only one of many options
and there will be more on this page as
time goes up this time goes on who uses
it the react ox View Docs Sequoia
Capital uses uses it for like fifteen
thousand pages smashing article magazine
for all their articles I like to
highlight the the corporate users Citrix
TriNet PayPal and particularly PayPal
like I like to talk about them we'll
come back to them but also nullified
comm this is the dynamic app that users
use people are always surprised to learn
that notified comm is hosted on Nell Fi
and I mean that's it's kind of
self-evident but for such a dynamic
authenticated behavior thing a lot of
people are really surprised that you can
build this kind of experience with just
in you know it's that excite and that's
that's also fantastic as well I like to
talk about the PayPal case a little bit
so this is a talk done by Jim on
Ferguson at PayPal done it in foq London
on bringing Jeff site to the enterprise
because they're not they don't use
notify they actually evaluated notify as
a vendor and they were really interested
in the staff but they actually couldn't
use us because of the financial
certifications that they needed us to
have and we didn't have it at the time
we since have we see this I've got that
certification but they move PayPal dot
me onto onto a giant stack architecture
and they built all that infrastructure
internally just to just to achieve this
and I think this is a fantastic talk for
Jeff second the enterprise financial
concerns so high security risks and a
large scale on the scale of PayPal so
highly highly recommend checking out
that talk as well let's talk a little
bit about developer experience I think a
lot of people put this front in center I
think it's it's a nice to have even
though I I work as a developer
experience engineer and I think the the
model for this is very simple like you
have local builds right you build
locally and you're you're developing and
testing and once you're
ready to deploy you commit to get and
then and then you're just building this
on the same sort of and it's in the same
model and you're just deploying to see
the end right this is a very intuitive
model because you can replicate anything
in production on your local local device
and that's actually something I worked
on primarily this year which is
replicating production environments on
your local desktop so you can you can
test it with a very strong one-to-one
benefit let's call the hell if I dev I
don't have time to explain all of it but
it's it's a very very fascinating
developer experience because you get
very fast iteration just you know
building locally alright here's the only
level five specific talk sort of slide
in the whole deck and notify we we take
the jam stack and else I sort of lived
and breathed and dies by serving the jam
stack developer and we we assume that
like given these the soul assumption
that you're working with the gems that
can you're building generous excites
what can we do with that and what
services can we build on top of that and
you can turns out you can do a lot and
so we can do a deploy previews branch
functions you can actually add service
functions alongside of your of your of
your front-end code and deploy them
atomically from front end and back end
so you you know in theory you never
break because you can just roll back and
forward and we can we add we had static
forms as well and then all this all
these other stuff all this other sort of
value added stuff I do want to highlight
analytics which was probably the most
successful launch
clarify this year and and that that is
basically server-side analytics which
are unblockable because you're not
including a bit of JSON the front-end
right like you're you're just you're
just reading CDN serving serving logs
and aggregating it in in a non
identifiable way which is gdpr
compliance which is fantastic especially
here so so yeah that's that's the whole
that's the whole journey to the to the
gem stack right like and and I think I
think it's it's it's behooves us to
really ask like why we why we're talking
about this and and it's really about the
changing platform in terms of computing
mobile has obviously taken over into as
the primary platform that everybody uses
particularly serve particularly to visit
websites but even on and but Eve
the time in terms of time spent that we
they were on mobile the web is actually
in a bit of a challenge right like most
of the most of time that we spend are
actually in EPS and not browsers and
that's a problem for the open web
because a lot of these you know programs
are behind either Apple Google and and
and that's that's a that's a big problem
for the for the open web unless we can
start to compete in in terms of the way
that we deliver software so that's
that's that sort of where we ended up
we're building and delivering all these
programs on native platforms and we
should also be able to build and deliver
and the answer to how we deliver this
software is with the Jeff Zack is by
coding by sort of building in that in a
sort of nice developer experience chart
to static assets and serving SATA assets
from CD ends to all the browsers yeah
and that's the introduction to Jeff's I
thank you very much
[Applause]